the final thing i learned from spending
a year staring into this abyss is that
we can win this fight
gender ideology is insane destructive
pervasive ubiquitous
and beatable
you know i get sure
i get um i get asked this
all the time
you know is this a hill that i'm really
gonna that i want to die on do you want
to die on this hill
and the answer is yes i'll die on this
hill if there's any hill worth dying on
it's this one
the hill of objective truth yeah i think
that's pretty important
i'll die on that
but uh but though i'm willing to die on
this hill i i don't plan on it
as general patton said back in the days
before the military cared about equity
intolerance more than killing bad guys
he said uh no bastard ever won a war by
dying for his country he won it by
making some other poor dumb bastard die
for his
well
i would say the same metaphorically for
this hill this fight for truth this
struggle against gender lunacy we can
win because the other side can be
crushed under the weight of simple
questions i saw this happen myself
before my very eyes time and time again
the learned the educated the experts
crumpled and collapsed and panicked
in front of me just this bumpkin wearing
flannel with a armed with a high school
diploma
running out of the room
is it because i'm brilliant
well those are my preferred adjectives
that's how i identify myself but
um no i don't have to be brilliant
fortunately
all you need to do is just stand up and
look this thing directly in the face
serve it a healthy dose of skepticism
force it to explain itself
the gender ideologues are weak and
scared and vulnerable they've perched
themselves on a limb that isn't even
connected to a tree they're anchored in
nothing their world view is empty and
frail and flimsy
we don't need to be armed with anything
but a spine
enough to stand up against them straight
just stand up straight and ask questions
questions that cannot be answered
questions that for that reason aren't
supposed to even be asked
but we must ask them
and if we do we'll win
and we must win